ruth phone call
hello
hello
you're gonna pay for what you did
i was in prison
i just got out
i was there for 20 years
for what
this accent
[Music]
does your release alter the terms of
your no contact order you don't have to
give me a speech i'm looking for katie
she's my little sister i raised her
okay next time don't drag me through
three bus transfers to tell me something
you already know
[Music]
john
there's a woman in the front yard can i
help you with something
if you're a lawyer
what would catherine gain by meeting her
now
i wonder all the time
what she looks like
when she became
your life starts here now not 20 years
ago
[Music]
she did her time she killed somebody in
cold blood
if that were any of your black sons who
had been in this system they would be
dead
she walks around like it never happened
no you tell me if that's fair you got to
be a convict wherever i go no you're a
cop killer everywhere you go
okay
just stop you're not i'm good
don't treat me like i don't exist tell
her about me
[Music]
pretend this is about her yeah i was
projecting her you are not a victim
i don't quit
not on katie
[Music]
[Music]
you